Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Bad Dream: Coma.
We're going into the forest now. Now this is an area that I have never seen be -oooooo, hey.
Ahhhhhhh.
Helllloo (markimoo is intrigued)
I gotta say the ambience in this game is... Wonderful.
Hello, anybody in these hidey holes over here?
Anybody..Oh. I'm not touching that flower.
Unless I got the glove.
No? Just No? Ok. I'm gonna keep the glove on,  just in case I got any goopers
that wanna be 'touched'.
Is that a stick i can have? No? Ok.
alright
Well,  this seems awfully unassuming.
But I don't wanna assume anything about its 'Unassuming' nature.
Alright.
seems to be pretty clear.
Alright... We're going in.
OH. I probably shouldn't touch that bear trap.(correct)
*Loud ambience*
I'm assuming that's the noise of confirmation (yep)
The 'Yes, Mark, that would be stupid to put your hand
in a bear trap
Alright I'm not gonna do that..
Heelloo?
Dink donk?
No not that way
Dink Pink
Can I throw a rock at your window?
Can I put my hand down? Why was my hand down for so long?
(markimoo is intrigued again)
Hi Poochy, how are you doing...?
Are you a rat? What's with your tail?
Hello...
Can I pet you? Would you like a nice tasty bear head?
How's your - *Loud ambience* OK
Thought you were gonna be upset or maybe it's just that I cant go any farther with you standing there...
Hey, a bird's nest.
Best not disturb it birds like me now, OK i got a key?
Dink donk?
Witches house... which old witch are we talking about here
ahhhh...nice meat..
ok... Clunk? Clumf? Clormf? Cloomf? Hey skull! Nice brooms.
Nice chest.
Nice jars..
Nice bookshelf...
Nice pot.
ok...
Can I light.. OOOooOOooOOooOh!
Well I did that?
So what's the point of that though?
Ughhhhh I don't want the meat. I'm gonna have bloody hands.
Ok, well, I got meat.
Maybe i can feed the meat to the dowwggy.
Maybe I could put the meat in the.. Oooh that would be bad, maybe I can just give it to the douggy?
The dog rat..
CRUUNCH. Ok, well, that's good. Better than putting it in the bear trap
and getting that all dead.
*Fly buzzes by*
Hello fly..?
Hi sir, HI!
Hows it going? You camping? Are you lost?
Am I lost...? I can give you a lift to town but first I need to chill and relax.
its so boring here.
It would be great if you found a worm for me
Alright!
OoOoOokk. Alright.
ok
alright
Sure. I've got a plethora of worms...back..
(mutters) God, that sounds weird in the left..
HEY!
What are you doing?!?!?!?
I don't know,  I just wanted to see the inside of your tent, man.
what are you trying to hide?
Don't go there!
Ok, there's something over here.
oooohh..
ughhh
Oh is that a...Oook i got a worm?!
Hey these puzzles are easy to solve :)
Everything is always immediately adjacent
Heres a worm
can you find me some bait?
I..I..I got a worm right...
I got a worm... OHH do you need more than one worm?
Ah is that what were talking about here?
also whats with the bloody tree that what i want to know
that's a body, that's a body (sure is)
OOOH hi!
I DON'T WANT YOUR WORM!
IF YOU GOT A WORM I DON'T WANT IT! *spooky noise*
eheheh
ok, well
this is a cheerful place
there's a leg
*bloop* there is another head *bloop bloop*
*bloop bloop b-bloop* k?
goody-goody-gumdrops
good thing that guy is chilling and relaxing in a place oh so chill and relaxed such as this
alright i'll find you some more worms
i guess
OHHHH can i poke that with a stick (yes you may)
*horn sounds* no that is dumb i shouldn't do that (oh)
ok..
alright then
carrying ohhhh
a car (yes mark that is a car)
hello?
oh this is that guys car
ok so i need to find some weeeooorms
were ever can i find some worms
alright there wouldn't be any in here
maybe i can find more weeeooorms
Wait -ahh! ehh!
w-oh well i didn't know why you'd?
are you so lazy i got to put it on your own fishing pole for you
What kind of weirdo are ya?
thanks man. now i need to get some rest
ok
you do that
ok al-alright
ok you- *spooky noise*
you do that i don't know what the point of that was
but ok
i guess i'll go rest
in the witches house
over there. Can I get some honey? Can I get some bear? Can I light you on fire?
Can I do any of that?
*surprise homeless man* OH! Hi! Hello! I didn't even notice you there.
Zuh ZUH zuh zuh zuh.
Energy drink recipe:
*Mark lists ingredients listed above*
....
Ohkaaaayyyyyyy..
Alright then.
Okay?
I'm gonna get a...spiny flower. With this gloooove.
AH HA
Got it! With the glooooove.
"Nasty Mushroom"
Now which one of these is nasty?
How do you KNOW which ones the nasty one?
I mean that's a little..
That's a little presumptuous.
*unidentified mumbling*
Alright so I guess I gotta make uhhhh..
I gotta make some sort of a-
POOTION
I gotta make a-
to BOOSH him out of the way.
Whatever he's doin'
ORRR maybe I can give the energy drink to the guy so that he feels all rested.
Just gotta find me a nasty shroom
Nah you all look pretty *blushes* (´・ω・`)
Honey??
Can I get some hone-low?
HELLO??
Can I get some hone-low??
*realization*
GRAIN!
Hey I got grain!
*Mark patting himself on the back on finding grain*
Yeah you gettin' rest?
Hey can I take that fish?
It's..a fish, okay I don't know what I'm going to do with a fish but I got it.
Alright.
Ohhh maybe I can get an-
OOOOOOH
I got that!
I don't know what that was!
Okay.
Do you have a nasty worm? (I don't think so Mark he is dead af)
Can I take your nasty worm? (I'm waiting till marriage)
Can you donate some NASTY worm?
*dissapointed* Alright, whatever.
I'm gonna get..
Oh THAT was the nasty mushroom!
*glitch in the mark system*
*quietly* okay.
Alright.
I assumed a nasty mushroom would be on the ground.
Let's see about tossing some of these in here.
Bloop.
A bloop.
A bloooop.
WHEN DID I GET THAT?!
When did I get a leech?!
OOoooOOhhh is it because I walked in the swoump?
...probably.
Welp.
I think theres only like
Uh
One or two more ingredients.
So we got the spiny flower, nasty mushrooms, rotten fish, dirty worm, leech, berries-
We need berries.
*with more conviction* we need berries.
Wait are we missing one?
I think we need a dirty worm and we need berries.
Dirty worm and berries.
Where we gonna find a dirty worm and where are we going to find berries?
Berries are gonna be in a BUSH.
I know berries are on bushes.
That's something that I do know.
So I just gotta find a berry bush so I can get what I need to get.
You a berry bush?
YOU a berry bush?
Berry bush bruh?
*gasp*
Are you?
Can I have you?
*gasp #2*
Can I put you in a jar?
*gasp #3*
I GOT BERRIES
I got berries in a jar for some reason.
That's what I needed to do with that.
Now I need to find a nasty worm..
A real stinker of a  worm.
A real son of a bitch-
*dramatic music caused by swearing*
Berries are in.
Alright so I need a nasty worm..
Oh!
Hey! :D
I got a worm from the fish pile?
That makes sense I guess?
Blop in you go!
Hey cool!
Come on!
Huh?
Well that's gotta be everything!
What else am I missing??
Okay-
We got the spiny flower, we got the mushroom, fish, worm, leech, berries, grain-
We got it all!
It's definitely all in there.
Sirrrr?
Your recipe is bullshit!
Oh!
Whuuuu?
oooOOOHHHhhhh..
I needed an empty can.
OH
I get it.
An energy drink needs to be in a can OHkay.
Lets fill that bad boy up with red-balls and give it over to our good friend here.
Hey you want some energy drink?
You wanna get some wangs?
Thanks.
*gross swallowing noises*
Alrighty if it doesn't kill him..
Cause I don't know I put a lot of weird shit in that.
Even though it mysteriously looked like that can in that garbage pile behind me,
*reading outlaid the dialogue from game*
Alright.
Oh a flat-
OHHHHH I SEE HOW IT IS
I gotta do ALL your chores for you sir?
*reading the dialogue*
Oh god I don't like where this is goin-
Why don't you find your own-
STICKY
-substance,
and I go off in the other direction?
Alright fine I gotta find a-
..sticky substance
I gotta find something...
*pause*
STICKY
Withhhhhh that? No.
Can I poke that with a stick?
Honey's pretty sticky.
*mumbling* ..yes.
Hello?
Ooh I get a fishing rod.
I bet I gotta fish over in...here.
Yeah oh thats-
OOOOOHOOHOO
*another glitch in the Mark system*
*the rumblings of shocked-i-plier*
You got a light?
Cuz I do!
You wanna...You want me to light this for you buddy?
Ok. All right. Thanks for that!
Thank you for that! Don't know why I got that, but I have that now.
*sound of disgust* Yee!
All right. Hey, buddy, you want a...
...you want a cigar-ay..you..you already got one. Thanks, but I got my own smokes.
Dot, dot, dot.
Ok! Then why did I need to fish this one out..*stutters*
I could j..ask you for one.
If i really needed.
Fine.
Oh, it...ohhh
Is it..? Oh!
Did the witch come back home and not like me messing around with the witch's stoooo...
*quietly* Well, someone seems to be gone.
*squishy and crinkly noises*
Hello? What was that?!
Whyyyyy did you do that?
Mmkay. I'll assume that I'm fine...
Still haven't figured out what I need to do,
but I'm assuming I'm fine.
Can I sti-
Can I stick this bear head in the window and scare the witch?
Wait! Doesn't smoke..?
Ah! Smoke...
*emphasized* Smoke...
Bees don't like smoke!
Or they do. They...they li-
Either way, they become complacent with smoke!
Eeeeeeew!
EEEEEEW!
Now i can get...oooooh..
Oh that's goo. I got GOO?!
Why's the...the bee...bees producing goo?!
I didn't want to steal the bee's goo!
That's the...exactly NOT what I wanted to steal.
Am I still ok?
All right. I'm still fine, apparently.
Yee...
Here, have some goo.
Hey! I made this fresh batch of goo.
You better appreciate it.
It's straight from the tap if you know what I mean. *wink wink*
Disgusting and stinky!
Thank You!
I pride myself on my stinky goo!
It's useless.
Well...
W...Fuck you, then!
Oh, fuuck you!
You took my jar and my stinky goo
and you're just gonna turn your nose and go, "Pooh, Pooh," to my goo?!
Well, fook you!
Fine.
Well, that was a useless turn of events.
Why did I even do that?
I fished... *chuckles* I fished a cigarette out of there for nothing.
Asshole!
Well, shit.
Now I'm back to square dickery.
OH, I didn't go in here!
Oh, this would've been smart:
to look in his stuuuff.
*exhales*
OW!
*sarcastically* Good! Used gum.
*annoyed* OOOOOH
Good. Here.
You want some of your own used gum, sir?
It should wor- *scoffs*
*confused, high-pitched voice* Why would that work and not the goo?
Give me a moment...
Are you gonna use my goo with that?
Ye...Honestly, you better use my goo.
*softly* Frickin frick you dude.
Frick you turnin' up your nose at my goo.
All right, well,
that's awfully nice.
Can we go now?
Done!
We're good to go!
All right. Good.
I feel like there was a lot in that level that I didn't piece together.
*softly* That's weird.
*loudly* Well, anyway, we're done with The Forest. YAAAAAY!
So, anyway,
that is the end of this episode.
Thank you, everybody, so much, for watching.
We're gonna be getting to the bottom of this...
mystery
very soon.
So, thank you, again,
and as always,
I'll see you
in the next video.
Buh-bye!
*outro music*